nous approchons à très grands pas du
dénouement ultime concernant l'histoire
des skywalker et même on peut le dire de
la trame principale en fait suite à vos
nombreuses demandes j'ai donc décidé de
vous faire un dernier trois théories sur
star wars 9 avant sa sortie
comme à l'époque et je peux vous dire
que ça me fait vraiment plaisir allez
maintenant passons théorie
trousseau
[Musique]
oui
alors je n'ai pas précisé dans
l'introduction mais cette vidéo est
dédié quand même à ceux qui comme moi
n'ont pas vu ou regarder des lic qu'il
soit vrai ou faux peu importe je veux
juste vous partager mes visions et ma
pensée sur comment pourrait se terminer
ce star wars neuf et donc du coup la
conclusion de la saga des neuf films
essayons de réagir logiquement star wars
9 et la conclusion de la nouvelle
trilogie mais surtout de la saga entière
et c'est un paramètre important à
prendre en compte ce qui veut dire que
même si le film laisse des questions
ouvertes où le potentiel espoirs d'une
nouvelle suite un jour qui sait eh bien
il se doit de clôturer tout ce qui
entoure star wars dans les films et ses
problématiques
tout d'abord il faut pour moi terminer
cette histoire avec l'empereur palpatine
la source de tous les conflits durant
les neuf films et également la nouvelle
trilogie
puisqu'il semble avoir un énorme impact
sur cette dernière rôle c'est l'empereur
sera vaincue à la fin du film
c'est obligé et comme je l'avais su
poser et les trailer semble le confirmer
l'empereur souhaite mettre en
confrontation caille lorraine et ray
pour potentiellement s'approprier l'un
des deux est effacé toute future
résistance du coup car le conflit ray
écailles lorraine peut faire basculer
beaucoup de choses la preuve avec ce
look
et justement si l'empereur doit être
défait l'origine des conflits de star
wars s'éteindront avec la confrontation
éternel des sites et des jedi le côté
obscur contre le côté lumineux bref le
mal contre le bien quoi les thrillers
laisserait supposer que ray se laissera
séduire par le côté obscur tandis que
ben redeviendrait plus un ice gaye que
ce qui nous a été proposé dans les deux
premiers films
en fait il faut avoir conscience que si
côté obscur il y a côté lumineux
il y aura et cela a été démontré à
maintes reprise dans le 8 pour mettre
fin aux agissements de l'empereur et à
toute la saga les réalisateurs devront
nous proposer une fin des adeptes du
côté obscur et du côté lumineux et ne
pas reproduire l'erreur de l'udc qui
voulait former des nouveaux jedi
c'est très subjectif ce que je vous dis
cela n'engage que ma vision dans
d'autres termes nous deux
à voir la fin du duel entre ray et key
lorraine pour ne laisser place dans le
futur cas de simples utilisateurs de la
force comme base qui n'ont pas
d'éducation de jedi ou de potentiel site
entre guillemets je ne sais pas si vous
voyez bien ce que je veux dire mais
l'héritage des jedi est un échec comme
l'affirmé luc il faut que ray soit la
dernière des jedi mais genre
littéralement tout comme kyle lorraine
le dernier adepte du côté obscur et
malheureusement pour moi pour que tout
ceci se stoppe cela sous-entend une
feinte macabre pour les deux personnages
ou du moins l'un des deux protagonistes
mais je ne vous cache pas que je vois
mal jj abrams faire mourir est qui et
quand même l'héroïne de cette nouvelle
trilogie est également caille lorraine
en vrai mais il se pourrait que ces
derniers décident d'abandonner leurs
conditions et se fermer à la force
au terme de ce neuvième opus ou
peut-être même se mettre en exil bref
ils ne doivent pas créer de nouveaux
jedi et de nouveaux adeptes du côté
obscur un côté engendrant l'autre tout
repose sur les deux protagonistes
et s'il échoue palpatine aura une fois
de plus gagner et l'histoire
recommencera petite idée qui m'est venue
récemment mais qui je suis sûr arrivera
vous le savez c'est jj abrams qui est en
charge de ce star wars 9 et vous le
savez aussi ce dernier adore les
références aux anciens star wars même un
petit peu trop
rappelez-vous de l'opus et qui faisait
énormément écho à star wars 4 entre la
mise en scène sur jack ou avec leur est
coincé sur cette planète est justement
luc coincé sur tatouine dans star wars 4
ou encore là-bas starkiller et l'étoile
de la mort bref je pense que vous
saisissez lité et bien il est quasiment
sûr pour moi à 100% que nous allons
retrouver la fin iconique de star wars 6
dans l'opus neuf avec la défaite de
l'empereur la victoire de la rébellion
célébrer et tout comme pour dark vador
key lorraine qui semble retrouver un peu
de l'umih ne meurt en tant que celui qui
a fait basculer les choses mais ce n'est
qu'une simple supposition
malheureusement pour lui il est haï à
travers la galaxie il est le nouveau
suprême leader après tout aurait aura
conscience de ces actions ainsi que très
certainement les ja ce dernier serait
inhumé
à l'abri des regards et la conclusion de
ouf ce dernier réapparaîtrait en force
ghost à la fin du film aux côtés de luc
et yoda tout comme anakin à l'époque qui
est réapparue au côté d'obi wan et de
yoda en vrai j'avoue c'est un peu du
troll mais cela pourrait clairement
avoir du sens car oui la symbolique est
grande et nombreuses sont les
inspirations et référence aux anciens
star wars
prenons l'exemple de l'udc ce dernier
dans star wars 8 a fait la rencontre de
ré et ne souhaitait pas l'entraîner à
devenir jedi
bien qu'il lui explique les bases du
côté de chez dice et yoda qui convaincra
le dernier des jedi à transmettre le
flambeau arrêt qui est un petit peu le
dernier espoir du côté lumineux
nous sommes exactement dans la même
symbolique de l'époque où obi-wan
convainquit yoda de prendre luc sous son
aile et à faire devenir de lui un jedi
car yoda était réticent à le faire au vu
des risques qu'il sombre comme son père
exactement comme pour la perte de kayes
lorraine par rapport à luc et la peur de
créer un nouvel adepte du côté obscur
avait créé néanmoins je vous avoue que
même si la référence à la fin de l'opus
6 me ferait énormément plaisir
j'espère tout de même que on n'aura pas
spécialement cette fin car cela voudrait
dire que nous serions face un calque
propres et donc du coup que tous les
arcs narratifs instauré dans cette
nouvelle trilogie mènerait donc à ça une
copie comme je les dis ben semble très
indécis et un profond lien lui ni arrêt
il se pourrait très clairement qu'ils
reviennent du bon côté pour défaire
l'empereur mais là où je pourrais avoir
tort c'est par rapport au véritable rôle
de ray dans le film et de sa véritable
nature
effectivement les trailer insiste
lourdement sur le fait que ray puisse
goûter au côté obscur et limite si elle
pouvait s'allier à l'empereur ray
souffre de ne pas connaître ses
véritables parents ou géniteur imaginer
une seule seconde que ces dernières
soient liés à palpatine de près ou de
loin
cela pourrait remettre clairement
plusieurs choses dans son contexte mais
c'est très très vite avancer dans tous
les cas malgré mes propos star wars 9
aura son unicité et son identité
soyez en sûr et certain et je pense
qu'il est impossible de
prédire tous que le film va nous
apporter dans sa globalité
il nous faut des réponses à voir
alors pour conclure je vais devoir
contredire tout ce que j'ai apporté dans
la première théorie mais bon après tout
ce ne sont que des théories des idées
des spéculations effectivement alors ses
personnels subjectif bref tout ce que
vous voulez mais pour moi et dans ma
pensée
mais si star wars doit vraiment se
clôturer du moins dans cette trame
principale les skywalker doivent
s'éteindre l'empereur doit s'éteindre
et si c'est vraiment la fin fin il faut
conclure aussi cette histoire de côté
lumineux et de côté obscur
néanmoins comme je voulais dit je ne
vois pas jj abrams faire mourir ray et
peut-être même key lorraine alors se
pourrait-il que ce ne soit pas vraiment
la fin définitive au début quelques mois
après la sortie de star wars est il
était prévu apparemment que ryan johnson
le réalisateur de star wars 8 devait
faire une trilogie qui aurait pu
symboliser star wars 10 11 et 12
avec de nouveaux personnages ce n'était
qu'au stade de rumeur mais cela semblait
bien fondé et au final ryan a bel et
bien une trilogie affaire apparemment
mais ce serait plus sur tout ce qui
entourait le l'or et le passé de star
wars pour rester général et pour
enchaîner c'est une problématique nous
pourrions développer dans une vidéo
dédiée
mais depuis le début nous connaissons
les intentions de disney à l'égard de
star wars
entre les nombreux projets de films et
séries et vous disent les ports gay etc
il faut faire de l'argent la saga star
wars rapporte et c'est un phénomène
international et ça je peux vous le
garantir l'avenir de star wars et sur le
petit écran et ce mandat lauriane subit
déjà un grand succès alors que la série
n'est pas encore arrivé chez nous mais
je suis prêt à parier que disney attend
d'avoir les résultats complets autour de
la trilogie du 7 8 et 9
et d'ici quelques années il se peut que
la saga principale puissent reprendre
il n'y a aucune preuve aucun fait dans
ce que je dis mais dans la politique de
disney cela pourrait bel et bien marché
néanmoins la saga principale est axé sur
l'histoire des skywalker et tout dépend
de la conclusion que star wars neuf va
nous apporter mais s'il n'y a plus de
rapprochement de près ou de loin avec
cette famille
il n'ya techniquement plus trop
d'intérêt autant faire une autre
histoire
loin de tout ça et on ne va pas se le
cacher mais disney a déjà beaucoup tiré
sur la corde
concernant l'histoire des skywalker bref
pour résumer l'idée c'est que star wars
9 puisse s'ouvrir sur une fin ouverte et
il y a de grandes chances que cela
arrive
l'idée de nous laisser sur une ouverture
concernant cette saga permettrait de
s'assurer de continuer l'histoire un
jour ou l'autre mais pas forcément avec
des films au vu des nombreuses questions
auxquelles nous aimerions des réponses
star wars 9 ne pourra pas répondre à
tout et disney a déjà commencé à
produire des choses à côté pour apporter
du l'or après tout la saga star wars
c'est également énormément de produits
dérivés de livres de goodies nous avons
l'exemple avec ce look qui est devenu un
personnage un peu plus fournie qu'au
début notamment grâce à des comics
bandes dessinées ou livre dédié etc
bien qu'il reste encore énormément
mystérieux car l intrigue total nous
apparaîtra dans 14 jours
évidemment mais est ce vraiment la
stratégie de disney de nous proposer une
fin ouverte pour justement continuer
d'alimenter l'histoire fin ouverte ou
non nous aurons des produits dérivés qui
enrichiront la saga soyez en sûr merci à
tous d'avoir regardé secours petit trois
théories et j'espère de tout coeur qu'il
vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser votre plus beau
pouces bleu un commentaire sur la fin de
la saga et à vous abonner bien
évidemment je vous encourage à me suivre
sur twitter et instagram de réseaux où
je suis pas mal actif maintenant et puis
écouté que le liner soit avec vous
c'était art rock
allez
[Musique]